we can State the matter starkly we
cannot be good lovers if we don't know
how to be vulnerable
we make ourselves psychologically
vulnerable whenever we let a partner
know some of the ways in which we're
weak needy scared immature incompetent
or just plain odd that is some of the
ways in which we're human
to be vulnerable is to dare to take off
the usual cloak of normality and
sensibleness with which we navigate the
world and for once to show someone who
we really are with all the fragility and
unusualness implied we might as
vulnerable people admit to a desire to
be mummied or dadied to curl into a ball
to cry over a so-called small thing to
be reassured about an apparently minor
flaw to call up our lover every 10
minutes to suffer from anxiety or
paranoia to speak in a regressive Voice
or hug a favorite stuffed animal
it's a hugely complicated step to
confess in front of someone we
fundamentally want to impress and secure
the affection of that there are basic
ways in which we fall short of what a
proper adult is meant to be like
a certain kind of no-nonsense partner
might well tell us sternly to grow up
complain about us to their friends and
make Hasty moves to end a relationship
as a result we often lie in love not for
advantage or thievery but in order to
hold on to a love that we desperately
depend on we pretend to be strong and
unafraid we put on a show of being
someone else such acting Works in many
contexts an uncomplaining Breezy
competence and unemotive intelligence
can make us an ideal employee an
admirable Committee Member and a
thoroughly respectable citizen of the
modern world
but in an intimate relationship this
form of caution is fatal our fears and
inadequacies don't vanish because we've
hidden them we don't get any less
childlike or odd because we've learned
to seem sensible we simply end up living
with someone who cannot know us and who
because they are likely to take their
lead from our own Reserve will not be
able to show themselves to us in turn we
enclose ourselves in a prison of mutual
deception
to dare to be vulnerable involves a
faith that whatever we are inwardly most
afraid and ashamed of in our own Natures
must have counterparts in other people
we cannot be alone in our Oddities the
only people we could assume are normal
are those we don't yet know very well
but once we are past their Flawless
exteriors every other person we meet and
especially the person we're now dating
will have their share of Follies they
will suck their thumbs be scared of
ghosts have psychological compulsions or
worry about the size of their ears or
the state of their friendships to be
vulnerable is in essence to let a
partner catch a sight of us that dates
back to Childhood the distant time when
we feared that mummy would never come
back when we cried and no one comforted
us when Daddy shouted at us and we were
frozen with Terror when a rough friend
told us we were a baby for Still Loving
our stuffed elephant when no one wanted
to play with us in the schoolyard when
we tried and tried to explain and Granny
was still angry
properly fully vulnerable is to take the
other person into the frightened small
places of our past and to let them see
that we are still in significant ways
the little distressed person we once
were honest vibrant love is an encounter
between two vulnerable children who
otherwise do a very good job of
masquerading as adults
what makes people reject the offer of
vulnerability the strength they display
is an indicator of how punishing they've
had to be towards their own fragile
inner selves it's a measure of how fast
they had to grow up if mummy dismissed
their nighttime fears they'll have had
to try to tell themselves desperately
that mummy was right and that crybabies
really are disgusting they perhaps
deflected the rough boy's taunting of
minko who granny knitted while they were
still in the womb and whose trunk had
half disintegrated under the intensity
of their Hugs by throwing the little
soft toy in the bin they manage their
traumas by siding with those who hurt
them they focused on keeping their room
tidy passing exams and learning how to
do business and so they came to fear the
very thing that they now most need an
unfolding restorative and profoundly
understanding tenderness towards that
traumatized early selves in a grim
Paradox to have words of empathy whisper
to them lovingly in the dark only
reinforces their deepest fears their
protective shell snaps ever more tightly
shut at the approach of sympathetic love
they respond to their own needs with
panic and self-disgust
we learn to be vulnerable by
understanding that those who conveyed
the imperative of a tougher non-crying
non-fragile self were profoundly
Incorrect and in their way probably
deeply traumatized themselves mummy was
dismissive of our fears not because she
was impressively astute in her theories
of human development but because she was
struggling with her own history of
unattended need the anti-minko friend
wasn't showing us the real path to being
a grown-up they were inflicting on us
some of the unkindness that was in other
contexts probably being directed towards
them
we need to go back and convince
ourselves perhaps with a touch of Anger
of how misguided our agents of growing
up really were
finding a partner with whom we can be
vulnerable constitutes a supreme Act of
restoration after a lifetime of denial
and full strength we stand to find in
another person the sympathy that was
sorely needed but unavailable to us in
the past the Old Wounds can be gently
tended we become stronger by learning to
speak the language of weakness by
letting our hurt babyish selves into a
relationship we open the way to a more
nuanced fruitful creative and accurate
idea of what it really means to be an
adult